So here's a question. Chronic yeast infections, chronic candida infections,
four years of constant infection and nothing seems to help.
Burning pain, sometimes a little itchy. My last test with the clinic still showed yeast
infections, supplement antibiotics, supplements, antibiotics, and diet.
And this yeast infection is still there, not sure what direction to go from there.
That's really difficult. Chronic yeast infections are really difficult.
The new course that we're going to have on holistic health and healing is going to have some
information on more specific than chronic yeast infections, but it's still it's a very
difficult thing to deal with. So whenever you don't want to make light of that and you already know
that it's hard, but when practitioners just say, oh, yeah, you're just going to take this
probiotic and things are going to get better. It's just not that easy. There's some things that you
can think about doing with chronic yeast infections that I will type out here. One can be doing
probiotic animals. So probiotic animals can be held. So that's where you mix probiotics into
just a warm water solution. And then you do an animal using an animal egg with the probiotic.
You're trying to hold it as long as you possibly can.
And that's probably you can look up how to do a probiotic animal. There's different
don't instructions on it, but you're basically doing it just like a coffee animal that you're using,
a probiotic water solution instead. Another thing that you can do is make a paste out of
a plate yogurt plus probiotics. So yogurt have probiotics, it's not very much. So you're adding
probiotics like a capsule, open up a capsule of probiotics to a half a container of yogurt.
You don't need a lot of yogurt. Mix it up and let it sit on the counter at room temperature for about
30 minutes. And then you actually have to take that in the shower and put that up your
porifices everywhere you can. You can gargle with it. You can eat it that way. So if you add
probiotics to your yogurt to eat, that's beneficial. Well, I eat yogurt all the time. It's not
helping. Well, there's not really truly a lot of pro living culture in yogurt. So you want to add that
to that. So that's one thing to do. You could actually do an animal with that as well. That's
another possibility. So when you add probiotics to yogurt and leave it sit for a half an hour,
it's going to kind of liquefy more because the probiotics are growing in there. It will kind of
break down the yogurt milk cultures. It'll become much more liquid. And you can,
then use that as an animal too. So then you get into more serious things to try to deal with your
gut issues. And that has to do with doing, you know, seabot protocols and different gut protocols and
healing gut protocols. And then even what's called a fecal transplant. So fecal transplants
really gross. But that's where you're taking feces from a healthy person. So somebody who does not
have yeast infections, this is really gross. But then you blend it up and you basically do an
animal with that feces. Boy, that's horrible. Well, there's so much living culture in that other
person's feces that it can be beneficial to help grow new culture in your gut.
Nobody wants to hear about that. But that's actually a fantastic treatment from colitis,
ulcerative colitis, inflammatory baldness, bowel disease. And it can be good for just horrible
product yeast infections as well. Certainly you want to start with some of the other ideas first.